claro liliana muchas gracias por la
invitación esto es muy importante debido
a que astrazéneca si una vacuna que está
ya garantizada en más de 100 países y es
una vacuna de las de mayor producción y
que quizás es la que pondría fin a la
pandemia uno de los elementos más
importantes cuando se autoriza una
vacuna es la parte de farmacovigilancia
que esa nunca acaba o sea hoy en día
seguimos con el fármaco vigilancia de
todo tipo de medicamentos vacunas aunque
ya hayan sido autorizadas aprobadas se
siguen vigilando precisamente para
encontrar en aquellos casos adversos
estas estos raros efectos que se pueden
encontrar en millones en la fase 3 de
astrazéneca no se encontraron estos
casos de strong osito penn ya de de
coágulos precisamente porque se hicieron
en miles de voluntarios pero cuando
comenzamos a inocular a darle a
pacientes a personas sanas a estas
vacunas a millones de personas sanas ya
se encuentran estos casos que en un
principio se pensaron era completamente
asociados de la vacuna porque muchas
veces es difícil
si están asociados a la vacuna o
simplemente es un caso raro que le
sucede a las personas y poder encontrar
ese vínculo es la farmacovigilancia que
hizo en el día de hoy como bien dices
tanto emma como la agencia regulatoria
de gran bretaña dijeron que se existe un
cierto vínculo un posible vínculo entre
estas coágulos que se encuentran en el
cerebro o en la fase de abdominal por
ejemplo con la vacuna de astrazéneca
entonces emma lo que hizo la agencia
regulatoria de medicamentos lo que
propone es que esto esté dentro de las
contraindicaciones de las vacunas así
como cuando tomamos un medicamento y
detrás vemos todas las letritas
chiquitas de contraindicaciones que una
de la contraindicación de la vacuna de
astrazéneca sea un posible caso de
coágulos claro sin embargo hay que
ponerse unos lentes liliana de beneficio
y riesgo y el beneficio de la vacuna de
astrazéneca es todavía superior al
riesgo por ejemplo aquí te traigo unos
números en menores porque además estos
coágulos se han visto principalmente en
mujeres
muchas de ellas fumadoras algunas que
toman anti medicinas contra el embarazo
consiste en anticonceptivos
anticonceptivos gracias si se este
entonces es bueno estar un poco
pendientes por ejemplo de algunos
síntomas como falta de aire dolor de
pecho hinchazón de piernas dolor
persistente abdominal síntomas
neurológicos como dolor de cabeza o
visión nublada manchas pequeñas en la
piel y fuera de la ubicación manchas
pequeñas en la piel como de sangrado
entonces estar muy atentos al aplicar
esta vacuna y principalmente en los
primeros 15 días la verdad que sin duda
sigue siendo un riesgo mayor tener kobe
19 que el riesgo de la vacuna bueno pero
también cuéntanos rápidamente en
contados segundos también se habla no
solamente de síntomas sino de 18
fallecimientos confirmados en reino
unido como usted misma lo decía poner
esto en riesgo el avance en las campañas
de vacunación tanto en reino unido como
en europa brevemente por favor
sí claro esto pone en riesgo porque
algunos países como por ejemplo alemania
suspende ya la vacunación en menores de
perdones y en menores de 60 años y por
el otro lado gran bretaña que había sido
uno de los grandes apoyadores de esta
vacuna desarrollada por oxford con
astrazéneca pues ya le empieza a dar
alternativa de otras vacunas a los
menores de 30 años